Welcome everybody to another zoom call
Where we do our best to answer your questions?
Feel free if you think of a question while I go through all these questions to feel free to chat them in
Or if you want to verbally speak in
Questions like we started to begin last week always like that
then
You have to unmute yourself everybody enters the settings are your mute
Have done mute yourself, but I do ask before you ask a question less. It's pertaining to the question feed answered
Way to get to the end and then you can unmute yourself and
Speak at will
Okay, we've got a bunch of other people on joining here, so hold on
And we'll get started
Okay, a reminder to go to use the member site go to the member site and you'll see on the homepage
You'll see in different announcements
You know, there's I don't think any new announcements for this week. I didn't post
But you'll see different announcements. You'll see a whole bunch of information how to get out of the zoom calls
How to ask questions on the zoom calls everything like that
So use the member site and remember the member site is different than the website the member site is what you alone have access to with all the added information
Okay, let's jump into the questions and let's get started
First question, how many times should I run the cold and flu rife program before trying a different program when I'm sick?
Okay, so when you're not feeling well
I have mentioned to a good thing to start running as some of the more generic programs like the cold and flu program
Um, it also depends on if you have a true rife or an atelier robin the atelier robin
Programs for infections get very specific
So with the atelier robin I was able to create programs that come from the DNA frequencies of the organism
So if you'll you'll see in the atelier robin I have everybody has a folder that says
You know, it's a folder so it says a a doctor cutters 11 harmonic kill
programs that's and there's a there's
I don't know
15 or 20 or 25
Different specific 11 harmonic kill programs for different
pathogens, so those are all pathogen programs
But in the I created that program before I changed all the programs to 11 harmonic so in the alphabetical list programs of the atelier robin
You'll see that there's a lot of pathogens that are very specific like very specific bacteria
Um, that
You know you might not even be able to pronounce the names
But I did it that way because there's no specific frequencies for those bacteria. There's a lot of those programs
with a specific bacteria
And specific viruses
Are fairly short. They might only be 10 minutes long
Um, so you have to run those over and over and over again
It's because there's only a few known frequencies that are very specific that are taken off of the DNA of that that specific pathogen
So um, but it's very specific now you would only do those if you knew
Specifically that you were infected with something like that which most of the time when you don't feel well
You don't know what it is okay unless you're
Running down and getting a sputum sample of your cough material and having it analyzed in a laboratory and then they're telling you exactly what bacterial
Infection is a viral infection. It is you're not knowing that so then it's better to run the cold and blue programs or
You can get this is with the true right or the atelier robin there's strip programs or strip and staff programs or
There's different
Cold and blue programs different you know flu on coming different strap strap, you know staff type programs that are more generic
And there's just a bacterial program
So if you don't know what it is that you're infected with you're just gonna have to run some of those
So for instance our whole family was infected with a really bad cold with a really bad flu type thing
That was just really wiped out literally everybody in the family
And we were experimented with different programs because everybody was so sick
So it's difficult to know unless you get tested exactly what you're dealing with is it a strap a is it
Strap B is it a is it a
Is it some sort of weird virus is it you just don't know so you're just gonna have to run the different programs
Now again if you're dealing with a sickness like that I suggest you run it 24-7 if you can
So you're gonna have to play with different programs see if you notice one that makes you feel better
So
You know, I just I do believe that in this day and age that we live in there's a lot of infections that are
Maybe altered in some laboratory somewhere, so it makes it more viral and or that it's gonna go around
Virulent I mean and it can make it more
Harmful to us as humans. So it's not just your regular
Average blue anymore. It's it's something that is
Created to be more virulent and more be more damaging. So you're gonna have to play with some different frequencies
To find out which one will work best for you. So I wish I had just a more perfect answer for that, but I don't
You're just gonna have to run, you know different frequencies as much as you possibly can
Um, okay next question
Which would be more helpful for use on a person with a hairline fracture in the knee
A true rife with a crystal hammer bulb alone
Or connected to the jackhammer amplifier
What's your opinion of the jack hammer amplifier?
And then the next part of the question would it be more beneficial to purchase the overnight tornado bulb and use that
This would be for daytime views
So
First of all, we're making the assumption that the rife machine is gonna be super helpful on a hairline fracture of the knee
um
I'm not saying that it can't be
I'm just not saying that
It
necessarily would be so if I had to again, I've said this time of time again
Um, these are tools all we have is tools. So the rife machine is a tool. There's a lot of other therapy tools
So if I had a hairline fracture of the the out of all the therapy tools that exist
Um, that I may have access to
Um, um, uh, what would I use? Well, if I had a hairline fracture of the knee, I would use laser that would be my choice
If I had a sprain uh, like a really bad ankle sprain, I would use laser
If I had a muscle contusion, a muscle pull, like I pulled a muscle, you know, doing pickleball or something like that
What would I use? I would use electrical stem like a tens unit or an EMS unit
Uh, some sort of electrical stem, Russian stem, something like that
Um, if I had a um
Frozen shoulder uh with um, calcific
Tendonitis or something like that. I would use ultrasound
laser could be helpful for that
Now, the rife can be helpful for all of these. You have a rife at home
So I understand the question. I already have a rife at home. I don't have a laser at home
I don't have a p-m-f at home. I don't have a hyper American home. I don't have an electrical stem machine at home
I don't certainly don't have a laser or an ultrasound at home
Um, but you may go to a carpenter's, you know, a therapist physical therapist that has those things
Um, and if if I had a hairline fracture of the
um, uh, laser would be
um, would be far superior I think, but you have a true rife so you could do it daily
So what would you use with the crystal hammer bulb alone be enough?
Yes, I think so. Do I need the jackhammer amplifier now? The true rife has a possible jack high-ever amplifier
Well, for those who listen to me very much, I'm not a big fan of the jackhammer amplifier anyhow
So I would say no, you don't need the jackhammer. You're only going
You're at your knee the hairline fracture of your knee
um, I don't know if it's your knee cap the patella or if it's the
it's more likely the base of the tibia
uh, it's uh
You know your your crystal hammer bulb is gonna be plenty enough to penetrate that you don't need the jackhammer
There's absolutely no need for that do you need to add the overnight tornado bulb
Would that be better? No
No, it wouldn't you again you just need the frequencies to penetrate
um, so no the crystal hammer bulb
um, is plenty adequate to do that there's no need to add anything else
But again, these are tools again the true rife to me for a fracture would not be the number one tool
I would use
uh, it would you know again the rife machine is going to be better to kill cancer to kill pathogens
um, yes, it could help heal organs and bring organs back to
It's normal frequency synergy like heat helping you heal the liver helping you heal
Which in a sense is going to help you with detoxification is it going to help you heal
soft tissue
Bone or muscle?
Yes, it can i tell my story of it healing my frozen shoulder
But uh, i tell you i've done i've had people use the rife on musculoskeletal things
You know based upon my story of it healing my frozen shoulder and and i've used it on other musculoskeletal things with
seemingly no real help
so i would just um
You know, we i would use it because i have it
But i would think about using other therapies
That maybe better tools in that instance
Next question
What are your thoughts on high dose hydrogen
magnesium
And by carbonate therapy. So if you're doing the um this person asked this question of me
In a phone consultation. We also had
um, and he's talking about those machines that use
Hydrogen that you're breathing in that hydrogen and it's magnesium and a bicarbonate
Um, i think those machines are great the hydrogen machines that are out there
Are really good years ago. I remember when they first came out
I was at a seminar when they were introducing them
It was an A4M seminar oh gosh about eight years ago. I can't remember who's track of time
And i almost pulled the trigger and bought one
But that was when covid was starting and we were
See less people in the office. So i saw i thought i don't know who i would use this on it
I think using it just
For a couple days of a person that's coming in from Kentucky or something like that. It's not going to help at all
So i didn't do it
Um at that time they were they're quite expensive. I think he mentioned that they came down
You know greatly in cost
So i do think they're good machines and i think they're they're beneficial
Now the only part of this question that i might take dispute is in standout chemo
I wouldn't necessarily say that anything takes the place of something else
So chemo therapy is very different than doing the high-dose hydrogen
And maybe they're selling it that way. Do it this instead of chemo
Um and maybe there's come other probably rife companies that are selling rikes do this instead of chemo
It's be careful with that terminology. I don't know if that is that what you meant by that
But instead of doing chemo can i try this first? I would say absolutely
But instead you know if like oh you're not going to tell you're a college or so i'm not going to do chemo
I'm going to do this instead they probably laugh at you. So you're not
You know
chemo is a very caustic substance
It can have a lot of benefits because it could kill cancer but it can have a lot of side effects
Where this is going to give you new side effects
But it's probably not going to give you equal and quick benefit. So um
It's it's combination of things that you're doing that's going to help with your cancer
I think this is one thing that would be just great to add to your protocol. So i think there we go
Next question what supplements do you recommend for kidneys? My urine while fairly clear is foamy
Um, why would it make recommendations for your kidneys based upon
um the look of your urine? So urine can be foamy for multiple reasons
Um, it can be foamy if a person is dehydrated that can cause a little bit of foamy urine
It can be foamy based upon your stream if your stream is quick
um
Or if you're using a um if you're catheterized
It's very common to have foamy urine just because of how it's emptied into the bag
If you have a if you have a strong stream you can have foamy urine and there's nothing wrong
This foamy this of a urine is not diagnostic in itself
So i would say you don't based your supplements based upon
That side you would
You'd based your supplements based upon other things, you know, whether it be a cheek swab tester whether it be
um, you know, the uh a blood test or toxicity test or whatever other testing you're doing some objective data
That's based that you're basing your choice on
So um supplements that you'd recommend for the kidney it's based upon what's going on with the kidneys
um and the foamy this of your urine really isn't telling me anything so
um
You'd you'd analyze what's going on with your kidneys and you do that through different blood tests
You can tell what's going on with your kidneys creatine levels your BUN levels
um can give you indication that there's stress in the kidneys
Symptoms like signs of kidney stones
CT scans MRIs things like that that you're giving you
Giving us data that you're having some kidney failure or slow
function in of the kidneys
There's lots of different nutrients that could help with that food would want to base it on that data
Um, so i wouldn't say it maybe you're not saying this, but let's say you're saying oh my
urethus is um fairly clear and foamy
What does that mean? Well
uh
It can be nothing so we'd have to get more data
Um, so i will if you know you have kidney issues and we'd want to take that data and make a decision on supplements
So there's a lot of different choices for this
What would kidney tonic general on the right for use work? It's interesting two kidney questions
There are two different people that ask this question
So on the right for she there's several kidney programs
um, and um
The kidney tonic general is just a general healing for the kidneys
So there's just known frequencies that are for the kidney itself
And remember i said the best use of the right is to kill pathogens or kill cancer cells
But also it can bring back general tone to cells
So there's known frequencies for the kidney and sometimes okay, so one theory of ill health is that
Let's say you're if my kidney stay with kidney
My kidneys are not functioning well
Um, they're they're vibrating a different frequency
Whether in the whole health so if you could hit them at their own frequency at the normal kidney frequency
Could you bring back normal cell residents and help bring back normal health
That's part of the idea of frequency technology
so um
Some of the like the
Normal iadreedal normalization program. So they're just their name different things
To partly depending upon my mood when i was naming them
So the kidney tonic general is just a general frequency different general frequencies for the kidneys to bring them back to tone
So well what if i have kidney stones is that a good one to run?
Oh, yeah, it can't be but it's probably not gonna help with it
I think there's a kidney stone frequency
So run that or stones frequency run that probably more so
So kidney tonic generally be if there's a kidney stones per se isn't really a
inherent
Issue with the kidneys meaning that there's no dysfunction of the kidneys therefore you
Formed stones stones are formed because of excess oxalates
Um, and
Sometimes our inability to remove oxalates from our got to that could have to do with genetic variants
it could have to do with dietary things
um, and um, it's not a
dysfunction of the kidneys therefore you formed stones so if i had kidney stones
um, i wouldn't necessarily run that program
Except that if i have kidney stones for a long period of time it can cause dysfunction in the kidneys
So therefore i'm trying to keep my kidneys healthy too so therefore i think it can be beneficial to run that program
Um, but it's not gonna help remove kidney stones or say
um, hopefully that helps just like if let's say i have cancer in the liver
To run the liver programs are that be good? Yeah, it'd be good because the cancer in the liver is causing dysfunction in the liver
But i have to run the liver cancer programs or
Whatever cancer is metastasized the liver it says breast cancer metastasized liver i'd be running the breast cancer programs to help kill the cancer in the liver
But the breast cancer metastasized liver probably causing liver dysfunction so it might be good to run the liver program as well
um, but i have actually put the liver program in just in everybody's program because you what it helps with detoxification
Pieces too, but there was just an example
Okay, next question
I took a kbmo fit 22 plus got permeability test about four months ago
One thing it showed me was a sensitivity to coffee so i switched from coffee enemas to
yearma mate enemas
I would like to retest
Does it make to retest make sense to retest now?
While i'm not doing coffee enemas and see if the coffee protein shows up at the test
Or would it be more productive to start the coffee enemas back up again and do the test after the coffee enemas again
For about a month and see if the coffee proteins show up again in the test
Well, this is long been the discussion functional practitioners
Whether you should okay, let's say same example would be i think a sensitive to gluten
So i went gluten free i've been gluten free for three months and then i did a
Blood test to find out if i have gluten sensitivity was that why is there should i go back on gluten
To see you know if i you know if i have more gluten peptide circulated my body and i get to pick up a greater sensitivity
um
The the way i've always answered that is okay. How do you how are you living your life
Yeah, are you not eating that food on a regular basis anyhow
And you plan to stay gluten free um yes, i plan to stay gluten pretty how i feel better gluten free
Okay, well then do the test again being gluten free or no, i want to go back on gluten
Well then it might be good to you know eat a little gluten and
Because i haven't felt any different being off of gluten will eat some gluten and then do the test again
If it comes back positive you
The gluten isn't a good example because if you have if you show gleaned peptides
um
You're probably never going to be able to go back on gluten
So that's not wasn't a good example in my question, but in this case i would say it might be better to go back
On the coffee animals do that for a month and then retest to see if it comes back positive
Because you do want to be on the coffee animals
So i think that would be the better test
So the question is really should i put my body under that environmental stress when i do the test
Or should i try to stay off of it and do the test um the argument is
If you stay off of it and do the test it might show
Negative now see i think you're okay, and then as soon as you go back on it again
You know your body flares up an immune response that you start making i gg and i g a antibodies against that
With this case coffee and you're back in the square and what again and you're and you're causing inflammation. So
I think it's better to put your body under stress in a case like this
Whatever you want to go back to then go then put it back under that stress and see if it comes up positive
I didn't even finish the question i'm asking in relation
To my breast lump which is very close to the surface while
A while ago i asked if it would be smart to do a contrast therapy he'd or cold over the lump to stress it
And you said yes to try that
I got to think and know that the contrast therapy also increases blood flow to the area
And i thought that was something that we're trying not to do with tumor so i
So can you explain the see me the conflict of this?
Well if you're finished with cold
I should have been more specific than you're not necessarily increasing blood flow
For instance, it's very common with somebody with a muscular skeletal injury. Let's say you spray your ankle
They say what do they say you know rest mean you know which is
You know to elevate and to put cool on it and to put you know always ice it and things like that
What's the acronym it's called rice it's rest
uh
ice
I forgot but
To help with the spray daco, but the truth is you know if you've worked with people with
Musculoskeletal injuries like I have years ago
Many times people react negatively to cold and they work act more positively to heat or vice versa everybody's different
So what are the ways that you can help with that is to alternate hot and cold just like do a minute of cold
a minute of heat a minute of
Cold a minute of heat and then finish with cold and see if that pumping action actually helps
um with the healing so um
That can be something to try um and
With doing anything like over a tumor or something you want to be very careful and be um
You know extra vigil to see if you felt like that
Made it in that did not feel good. I would say make it worse right away, but
It wasn't helping um and and then you would scratch that but everybody's a little bit different and
You know, it's worth a try to see if something helps
Next question. I'm a new rife user. I have a daily overnight program and also three shorter daytime programs
Which should I run if I have time during the day? Can I tell how long the day programs are
So the daytime programs they're not in order or anything your overnight programs are
In any order whatsoever either doesn't make a difference if oh
Shoot today's Wednesday and I realized I ran Thursday's program
So what then just run Wednesday's tomorrow or just run Thursday's again tomorrow. It doesn't make any difference
Oh, which day program should I run it doesn't make any difference so just start with the first one
They can be you know, I don't remember on everybody's program how long they are but as soon as you open
Hit open up that program and hit run. You'll see the countdown timer. So you'll see how long the program is
So what if it's two hours and I only have an hour just run it for an hour then um, you know, what if it's you know
What if I only have 15 minutes just run it for 15 minutes then and turn off if you have to get up and go do something
And you're not coming back. There's nothing wrong with that. There's no wrong way to do it
There's no there's no wrong way to run any of your programs
So don't don't get hung up on thinking you have to do those things
Right the wrong way to do it is to not do it. So
um
That's the wrong way to do it. So you just want to run those programs
When I was in the thick of my cancer. I was running
Literally I've said this
dozens of times I'd get home and sit in my chair
I had the right right there and I turned it on and I was running my program
If I got up to go eat or got up to go do something
I just let it run and I came back and sit down. Sometimes it was five minutes later
Sometimes it was an hour later. It was just running my whole overnight program
So I ran my overnight program as soon as I got home
And then when I was ready to go to bed
I turned it off and turned it back on and ran my overnight program all night long
And then when I went to work, I was running the rife all day at work
Now I wasn't always sitting at my desk
But when I was sitting at my desk, I was getting the frequencies
But then I'd get up and go help people go do things and I came back and sat at my desk
And I was running the rife program all day long
So I was getting as much rife time as possible
But you know again, I was in a situation where there wasn't any other hope for me with my cancer
So I just I had to hit this as hard as I possibly could
So I just think the more rife time you get the better
Within reason, I don't want you to not live your life because you have to do the rife
I want you know if you have to go play with the grandkids go be with the grandkids
But you know you want to while you're sitting and doing nothing
reading a book or so either
Watching TV rather be running the rife set up your host that you can do that
And that's there's no wrong way to do it if you're doing it if you're just running the programs
If vomit is a side effect of chemo how bad is it if I can't keep down my supplements
Well, let's take one step at a time and and um you know vomiting can be a side effect of chemo
But usually people doing chemo even at the worst
Would be extremely nauseous after chemo for a couple days
Sometimes it doesn't hit them for a couple days after their infusion
And then they're super sick for three four days and they can't eat anything or they
They could eat a little bit they can take part of their supplements
They can we just work through whatever we can do
Um, sometimes people don't aren't vomiting at all. So
Sometimes they just have nausea and we have some different herbs and some different homeopaths for nausea if you if that's the case
So one step at a time
Um, we just do the best we possibly can
Um, and it's not like it's there's times when I was really shooting super nauseous and I couldn't didn't take any supplements up there
The need anything that they it's just
It's cold one day at a time
Get this question a lot. How often should I get blood work? Well, it really depends on the person. So it depends on
each person
What their previous blood work was
At each person what they are doing that could alter their blood work. So all right. Let's use the example number one
What their previous blood work was if your previous blood work was completely normal
um
Then
You can you know, there's more of a time that you could wait to get another test
If your previous blood work was abnormal that I will tell you ask me I will tell you when we should get more blood work
um
Because we want to look at those abnormalities and see what we need to do if we can do anything
To alter those objective findings
Number three is the person who's doing something that could
Hinder
Their blood work or cause some amdoral findings and the best example would be you're taking fenbenzo
So if you're taking fenbenzo we would need to get your blood work at least every 30 days
Um, because we need to make sure that you're not getting liver issues from the fenbenzo
So make sure we do that
So that's my rule and I've stated it a hundred times if you're doing fenbenzo
We need to get your blood work every 30 days and the only exception of that is if we've gone 30 days
Oh, it hasn't hurt my liver markers at all. We do another 30 days. I still I'm taking fenbenzo
You know, maybe daily and it's it's not has done anything to my liver markers. Okay. Let's wait two months now
So if it's good to affect your liver, it's gonna affect your liver
You know usually relatively quick within the first month. You're going to see you know your alkaline phosphatase
ST and ALT possibly go up
Because it's negatively affected your liver
So if you're doing something that's negatively affected your liver
Or if you have you know, an increased next example would be a change in symptoms
Um, I've been doing really well
Uh, and um, I haven't had blood work for three months
But now I'll sudden it's just something's wrong with it just exhausted all the time
I'm just super fatigued. I don't feel good. Okay. We need to get some blood work and find out what's going on
So if you have a change in the subjective finding
Then we need to look at objective findings. So um, those would be things up top my head
There's probably others, but those would be things up to top my head why you would get
blood work
Okay, that was all the submitted questions
Let's go to your chat if anybody needs to speak in a question. Just unmute yourself and we'll do that too
First question. I was just offered the use of full bloody full body red light for 30 days
Uh, sorry want to know if there is anything I should know about how to use this
Well, there's a lot of different machines out there, but I would I don't know um
What is recommended for that machine
But yeah, I would use it. I mean again, I'm not this super hot trough person on red lights on that best person to ask for that
But I don't think there's any harm in it. I just think they're oversold and overhyped
But I if you have access to it for 30 days, I'd use it every day. I'd use it every day for sure
Next question. I have to sleep on my back for comfort
It doesn't work to put the bulb on my belly
Too round bloated is it okay to put the bulb on top of my thighs right below my belly or should I put it on my
Bed by my side. I think either one is fine
Um, either either one is fine. It's still gonna
You're still gonna get the frequencies doesn't make any difference. Whatever's more comfortable for you honestly
I would think on your side would be more comfortable, but
Next question unable to digest protein will cause phobia urine best herb for kidney is erva earthy
Yeah, there's a lot of good herbs for kidneys, but depends on what is going on
Unable to digest protein will cause phobia urine
Maybe in some instances. I wouldn't diagnose that based upon
That's just me. I just wouldn't
It's
Just certainly saying you know, there's a lot of things that I'll turn into medicine that I've been exposed to over the last
How many years have we do this? It was 40 years. This will be my 40th. This is my 40th year
Oh my gosh, you're getting old
You're my 40th year of practice. I can't believe it
Um
Lots of different anecdotal things like that and there may be truth to that
Inability to digest protein will cause phobia urine
But I wouldn't put my
Stock in a lot of anecdotal things. We just have to be careful
Um, uh, so that may be true
And maybe need digestive enzymes while it's a pretty good honest truth that pretty much everybody needs digestive enzymes, right?
But um, so that could be the case
Um, but I would still want more data than just phobia urine
Next question. You mentioned herbs or meopathy for nausea's
If I prescribe nausea meds with my chemo should I get these other options to try first?
Um, I think it's always good to try
None medications before trying medications
um, I
Who
You have to be honest and say that lots of times medications are going to work better
Um, but they're not without side effects. So I mean, oh, I don't think anybody can argue that pain meds
Can do a great job of taking care of pain can get rid of my pain
Um
Probably better than anything else
Especially if I got serious pain, but it also comes with
Side effects. So you always try to do things
Is natural as possible for all sorts of reasons
Um, so I would definitely try that first, but I would get I would go ahead and take the prescription. So you have it
Um, and if you have to use it, you have to use it um, but using some of the herbs and meopathy for
Um, some symptoms can be
Can be helpful the ones for nausea can be helpful
But I've had people that are other anti-nazi medication
Over the years and they still are in horrible nausea and they use both so um
It's uh, you know, everybody's a little bit different that way
But we have nobody unmute themselves and ask a question today
Come on
Yeah, you can do it. I'll mute yourself
And ask a question
Okay, can you hear me? Yes
All right, so I finally got my
Glute meter my glucose meter and I started poking my finger and I finally got that down to
Understand how to get some sort of a consistent reading
Why do you say seven B is kind of the target to
Set as a goal
Well, there's been a lot of practitioners that take care of cancer patients
That um, you know, you've read things about you know, okay, so let's take a step back
Why are we trying to get blood glucose levels down to the first place?
Well because
You know every cell
Um, they're first you make energy
Um for a cell
primarily through
glycolysis meaning you're breaking down glucose
Um, and cells also break down fatty acids to make energy through the fatty acid cycle
But the number one way to make energy for a cell
And a cancer cell the same is you're breaking down glucose through glycolysis
So
You could say the number one fuel source for cancer
Is is glucose
So um
Now it's it's even worse if you have h i f one a genes
um, then you're even more prone to fuel cancer that way because
um, through the warburg effect
We'll get into that. I have some videos on that
So it makes sense to try to get glucose levels down. So everybody
Everybody's gotta go on a low sugar diet
Uh, low glycemic index diet, you know, you're trying to get your blood glucose levels down
Um, now you've also seen books that were written about every cancer patient should be on a ketogenic diet
Well, first of all, that's not completely true
Um, because a ketogenic diet in itself can be as it can have other problematic effects because
Some people's cancers can be fed off of a methanine and a ketogenic diet is going to be extremely high in methanine
Typically a ketogenic diet is going to also be high in dairy unless you're going on a dairy-free ketogenic diet
Which is much more difficult and thirdly really being on a ketogenic diet try to get your body into ketosis
Which gets your glucose levels down into the sixties
Is extremely difficult and if you're over 30 it's really there it's it's
It's
Almost impossible for most people to be honest unless you're like this fitness guru that all you do is work out
Every day and you're 55 years old and you have the body like um, you know some movie star
But that's not everybody most people, okay?
So it's very difficult to get into ketosis
So putting that pressure on a cancer patient. I don't think it's fair
And it also i'm sorry, but it takes all the joy out of your life because you don't you can't have any social
Interactual with anybody over food anymore
Because you're on a ketogenic diet
So but you can be on a keto-like diet and still have good social interaction
You can still live with your grandkids and have family functions and you're just not eating any sugar or your
Do you don't stay it away from high glycemic foods
kind of like a diabetic person shut, right?
Um, and it's been shown I mean the guy who wrote the book
um
About everybody of your cancer patient to be on a ketogenic diet isn't even a clinician. He's just a
Scientist looking at data, but he never treated one patient. He didn't treat patients
Um, I've had interaction with a lot of clinicians doing this
And in my experience over 30 years of doing this is you could have just as good of results
With shutting down the field source of cancer just
Cutting way back on sugar and be on a keto-like diet. I just named it a keto-like diet years and years ago
So you're you're not trying to put yourself into ketosis
You're just trying to get your glucose levels down
And there's other data out there that if a cancer patient just gets their glue
It got their glucose levels into the 70s, which is very difficult in itself. So I'll talk about that
They really have this the exact same benefits as if they got into ketosis
So um
That being said
It's getting a glucometer can be beneficial because it can be a guide and to keep us on the straight narrow under diet
Because get a glucometer test my blood glucose
In the morning at a 10-hour fast and it's 105
Well, that I mean you're already in syndrome X you shouldn't be over a hundred nobody, right?
So um you're already way too high even if you didn't have cancer
So that gives you some incentive. Okay, I need to clean up my diet
Pretty much everybody unless they already have
Going into their cancer. They already have
severe syndrome X and or worse. They already have diabetes
Um, it was never diagnosed. I've had people like that that
So they're fasting blood glucose is 155
And you know, they do everything they can't get it. They're they're any of diabetes. They didn't even know it. So
um, but let's say it's let's go back to our
average person 105 now you're starting to clean up your diet and you're getting it down
I could get it down to 90 and it's just can't get it down
I had it at 88 one day and it was 93 the next day
There's a lot of people depending on what your age is
You know, even if your diet was perfect, you're never getting any lower than it
And again that same person even if they want on a complete ketogenic diet
They're never getting the ketosis
Because getting those blood glucose levels down is not solely
dietary
So how's that how could my blood glucose level still be
90 when I don't eat any carbs whatsoever
I've been so good. I don't need any carbs whatsoever. It is still 90 in the morning
Well, because your body has another process called gluconeogenesis
That means you make glucose
So your body makes glucose. Why is that?
Because glucose isn't the preferred fuel for every cell
So your body makes glucose glucose is the preferred fuel for your brain
So in the middle of the night you're not eating anything you're on a fast because you haven't eaten since you know
Seven o'clock the last night and you're it's now two o'clock in the morning
You've been on a six hour fast so far and your brain needs glucose because your brain never sleeps your muscles don't need the glucose
They're not even doing anything you're just laying there in bed
But your brain needs glucose because your brain never sleeps your brain is always functioning. You're always firing neurons
So you actually release
Hormone that stimulates your adoretals to release cortisol in the middle of the night for the sole purpose of you breaking down
glycogen stores in the liver to supply glucose to keep your blood glucose levels from crashing
So it feeds your brain in the middle of the night
So you have two main processes
I should say three main processes for your glucose levels dietary glucose
ever one
gluconeogenesis your breaking down muscle to make glucose and break down of glycogen stores
Which glycogen is multiple glucose molecules put together in a giant molecule
We call glycogen that's stored in your liver
For when you're fasting
So that's even overnight fasting
So your body is creating glucose is storing glucose
For the use of your muscles for the use of your brain
And unfortunately for the use of any cell that is calling for which cancer cells are highly metabolic and they're calling for glucose
So
You can't get your glucose level too low if your glucose levels go too low you'll go into coma
Because your brain shuts down
so
But you if you could get your in a perfect world if you could get your glucose level into the 70s
Not 70 but in the 70s
You'd basically be
Functioning from a from a cancer standpoint
Is this literally the same as if you're going to do it a ketogenic diet
So
Side note ketogenic diet you're getting your glucose level in the 50s and 60s
And you don't have enough glucose to burn so you start burning ketone ketone bodies
Um, you don't need to do that for most cancers. I mean for brain cancer
um
Gleoblastoma I would work even harder getting that down
um, but even if if you're 50 years old and
Gleoblastoma you're still not getting it ketosis
So it's um
Trying to get your glucose levels down as best you can
Now the pro again the problem is there's depending on what age you are depending on what how damaged your cell membranes are and stuff
There's some people you could literally go on a ketogenic diet
And be religious about it and you never budge
You'll never get into ketosis
Just because you just took too much damage of cell membranes and there's people at a really good diet
Trying to get their glucose levels down and they can't budge below 90
Um, and you may know I've dealt with diabetes patients in the past when they come to me and their glucose levels are
240 and they could go on a perfect ketogenic diet. They can't budge their glucose levels below 180
It can't it's just they can't it's important. They just can't their cells are too damaged. So um
Hopefully there wasn't too much to answer that question, but it's so can I ask a follow-up question?
I can't tell from the okay
So free you I had an integrative doctor that I was going to that arbitrarily just put me on that foreman
I've never had free diabetes or diabetes and I don't believe I have it now and
I'm not above 100 with the glue
month the
glucose monitor thing
Uh, I was gonna keep taking it just to help but um
I think the oncologist said that I can do whatever I want, but it's his
Recommendation to get off of it because your body starts to get reliant on it and then it
Then it then it really loses its effectiveness. What's your opinion about um,
Who's forming anyway?
Um, you know, I don't I meant for a bit is
Uh, a drug that is used for diabetes patients to get their glucose levels down
Um, and that's the first go-to drug in a newly diabetic patient
newly diagnosed diabetic patient and it works pretty well
So um, the idea is well, why don't we just put cancer patients on met foreman to get their glucose levels down
Well, if you do that without changing their diet, you're not really
Ultimately helping the person, but let's say you're talking about diet
You're trying to get them on a low sugar diet and and we're gonna use met foreman
I don't see any problem with that
Is there a possibility that met foreman is gonna stop working because your body gets used to that?
Well, yes, there is
Is that necessarily a bad thing? I mean, it's like stopping using it, I guess
So um, I I guess I would be opposed to any cancer patient using met foreman as well
The only negative is is that it's a drug and it has negative effects and it can have negative effects on one's liver
So um, again, just like that other question. Should I use a medication or should I try to do an herbal approach?
I just think it's always best to not use drugs if possible
But for a person who can't get their blood sugar level down that can be another support
Um, but it can be a crutch for some people to think that they can just eat
A bad diet, so you have to be careful of that too
Thank you. I have a quick question. Can you hear me? Yes
great
So right now I'm off vitamin C pre-ear instructions, uh, but vitamin C supplements
Why do people recommend IV vitamin C and is that different?
It is because of dosage
So I do have an article on the website that says
Hardest it's titled hard to see oxidative stress to kill cancer
And it discusses this and some videos on that too
But in short
oral vitamin C um
Is always going to be taken unless you're taking really really high doses of it in a form that's well-informed
Um, it's at a dose. Let's say you're taking a thousand milligrams of vitamin C
That's a typical dose of vitamin C
That's a dose that the vitamin C is going to act as an anti-oxidant so you're going to have the antioxidant benefits of vitamin C at that dose
Truth is if you're taking a thousand milligrams capsule of vitamin C you'll probably absorb half of it
Um, so let's say you're taking
3000 milligrams of vitamin C you're probably going to absorb half of that
Um, so you're still only getting 1500 milligrams and you have to really get up past about five grams
5,000 milligrams for it to actually flip and start function as an oxidative agent
So um, it's really hard from an oral standpoint to get enough vitamin C in orally and absorbed
It's not just how much you swallow. It's how much you absorb at one time
So one person is asked why did I get 10,000
uh, milligrams of vitamin C 10 grams a day
So that's kind of like getting an IV
Okay, yeah
Well kind of if you're taking 10,000 milligrams, you're really probably absorbing about half of that
5000 milligrams. Yeah, I do it over the day so it doesn't hurt my stomach. Well, if you're doing it over the course of a day
Then it's you're then okay, throw that all out because you're over over six hours. You're getting 5000 milligrams
Then it's completely anti-acting as an antioxidant you have to get it in one dose at that to act as an oxidizing agent
So there's certain nutrients
Based upon dose
We need a low dose
That will act as an oxidizing as an antioxidant so like vitamin C and a lower dose vitamin E and a lower dose selenium and a lower dose
Act as an
antioxidant
Which is good and can prevent cancer
But once you have cancer and you take that you actually could be helping keeping cancer alive
So you don't want to be taking those things at the normal
Oral dose you have to take it at a much higher dose
And with vitamin C you have to get up to five to 20 grams to really get into the oxidative
Dose of vitamin C once it's oxidative. It's a cancer killer. So thereby
Taking IV vitamin C, which is typically going to start at 15 grams
um
Many clinics will start at 20 grams and some clinics will go up to 80 grams
You're getting a very strong oxidative effect. So therefore it's acting similar to chemo and killing
Well, just like so many of the other supplements that I put people on it's ox they're oxidative
So the supplements that we use for cancer are oxidative
You don't want to be taking antioxidants
If you went and got chemo it works because it's oxidative
You don't want to be taking anti-oxidants
So that's why I took you off vitamin C because the dosage that you could possibly get orally
Is it going to be anti-oxidant
It would mean negating what we're trying to do
So we don't want to be taking anti-oxidants
So that article hard to see the oxidative stress to kill cancer will help
You understand that I have a number of videos where I explained this very same thing
We want
oxidative stress to a cancer
Um, the benefit of using natural things to create an oxidative stress like vitamin C like all the things I have you on
Um, is that it spares healthy cells. It doesn't do damage to healthy cells, but it will tip over cancer cells and kill them
um, the benefit of chemotherapy to cancer patients is that it's oxidative so it kills cancer cells
The negative is it doesn't spare healthy cells. So that's the downside of chemotherapy
chemotherapy is actually far more oxidative than
You know doing iB vitamin C or doing you know
Prodicellular doing you know all the stuff that I have everybody on which is oxidative chemo therapies even far more oxidative
But the negative is everything's got to catch 22 here the negative of chemotherapy
Is that it doesn't spare healthy cells media it will be damaging to healthy cells
What are if you are doing an alternative approach
That's oxidative it's not gonna hurt healthy cells. So it's um, that's the pros and cons
So it's it's that oxidative effect that we're trying to obtain and we're staying away from anti-oxidants
I realize it's very confusing. So that's why we
Make videos and try to explain this and that's why we have long posted best try to explain
So ask these questions at the what the zoom call is for is these very questions. So good question
Any other questions?
Good questions today
Okay, I'll go with one more. Thanks for sending out the seminar link. I'm assuming you went a couple weeks ago or whenever it was
It was there anything in particular that you found especially new and useful?
Um, no, I did not go to that seminar
um, so I can't
advocate
Specifically for I just like some of the speakers
So
That's why we said doubt that
um, there's certain
There's certain people I highly respect in our field
And then there's others that I don't respect as much, but there's
Uh, and sometimes those people have the bigger name, but um, there's there's a lot of people that I really highly respect
Um, and typically those are people that I feel like they're
They're humble and they really do their homework
um, so um
Uh, and many times they're less well known
Uh, but there's like people like Dr. Peter McCullough that I highly respect. He's very well known
Um, but he knows his stuff
I like people that are intelligent. I like people that can convey
their intelligence in a manner that's understandable
and um, and
Are not uh, speaking really high off their horse and thinking that they're
Better than they are and I like people that speak with um, in ways that
um
Are trying are just speaking the facts and not trying to be
Dogmatic or trying to sell something. So I like that too. There was a few speakers in that category that
I'd liked so
Anybody else
Well weapon formed against the shell prosper
Praise God. Let's
All pray that together
We just have to be in prayer. I asked that you guys are in prayer
Um, not just for yourselves, but for others
I really do believe that
God gave me cancer
To change me and to change
and to
Re-enforce my relationship with him
Um, and I pray that you find that answer for yourself as well
God allows us to go through difficult things
so that um
For a zillion reasons, right?
But certainly one of them is to build our relationship with him and to grow stronger in our relationship
And our dependence upon him and our love and our need to love and be in prayer for each other
so um be praying for everybody. I ask that you guys are praying for us and be praying for everybody else
In our group of patients here and um know that God has a plan that everything that happens to us
All right, but that will be to do and we'll see you guys next week. Hopefully everybody's getting the hang of the new people are getting the hang of this
Um, zoom call and make sure you use the member site as much as you can. God bless everybody
Bye-bye